cyril faire un prix parce que je sais
que c'est tombé et le monde attend que
j'aime beaucoup laurent roger beaucoup
aux tic jean mouloud aussi qu'on a aussi
adoré chopin on a new look est fou de
toi on a les mêmes aussi manque t-il
fait part dès 2004 aussi alors tu as
cité arthur et moi donc j'ai besoin de
savoir que celle qui l'incitent g dans
ton coeur
bon cela je vais te donner des
situations a pas de me dire qui tu
choisirais tu vois ton bas de la rue il
y a deux colosses qui t'attendent
visiblement ils ne sont pas là pour te
demander à celle-ci pour t'accompagner
préserver la sécurité tu choisis arturo
acuna
je sens que dans certains cas tu peux
être un petit peu belliqueux alors
belliqueux très pote avec une carnation
elle te demande de lui présenter un mec
avec qu'elle peut passer une soirée
torride tu choisis arturo acuna
on va choisir article tu as envie de
passer une soirée avec elle on n'est pas
franchement non si on a les yeux qui
veut gagner des millions tu sèches sur
la question à un million qui a droit un
appel un ami capelle arthur ou cyril
hanouna
c'est d'ailleurs des millions c'est pas
évident horrible rappelle arthur ci
seront éventuellement il peut me traiter
j'espère avoir tu rappelles il vient tu
arrivé un truc de dingue pendant une
soirée tu t'es rendu compte que la nana
cta et que tu a embrassé ne s'appelle
pas roberta mais roberto à qui tu
confies secret à toi pauv con fiance tac
de la dernière chance pour toi tu ne
remplit pas ces la faillite sur qui tu
comptes pour te faire la meilleure promo
possible dans ton émission a pas facile
moi je vais dire arthur parce que tout
est jamais venu me voir jouer
je sais que tu m'aimes
je sais que tu regarde toutes les vidéos
assez que tu regardes les films mais
il est venu plus souvent privés d'accès
à [ __ ] d'amos se suspectent d'avoir
passé le week end avec une autre tu as
besoin d'un alibi pour te couvrir tu
appelles arthur ou hanouna [ __ ] c'est
horrible un appel qui tu appelles les
deux lorsqu'à la chapelle les voilà la
justice fait le copine qui connaît pas
paris veut visiter la capitale
malheureusement tu tu as besoin de
quelques jours pour un tournage vers qui
tue pour l orienter son bas le cap sans
aucune crainte quand il sourire que tu
m'avais dire artur mas a fait beaucoup
de latitude que tu as peut être très
moche dans ces cas là ça me fait surtout
si tu la vois s'avère d'ailleurs enfin
pour te protéger du coc vide tu as deux
masques un masque avec le bas mais non
cyril hanouna et un masque avec le bas
d'arthur tu prends lequel imputera est
battu c'est quoi je t'offre les deux et
c'est franchement c'est beau ça et ben
voilà c'est pour toi c'est essayer
essayez de vous rappeler gauche et
alexandre allez on vend